pop
ah ah
et sarah dans le tout nouveau secteur du
cimetière de téhéran
là où sont enterrés les quelques
milliers d'hommes et de femmes qui ont
été tués lors des affrontements
précédents le renversement de la
monarchie
le 30 mars veille du référendum qui
consacrera la république islamique
les familles sont venues nombreuses
pleurer leurs morts est célébré leur
martyre depuis la révolution c'est en
effet pour les téhéranais un acte
militant
un engagement face aux disparus de venir
ici tous les dix jours selon les règles
du deuil chiite
le schisme cette religion dissidente de
l'islam traditionnel a toujours
représenté en iran la contestation
l'opposition à toute forme de pouvoir
pour la première fois elle se trouve
être la religion officielle et le
pouvoir tout court
dans ce cimetière un premier signe à
interpréter à cause d'un interdit
religieux seule figure sur les tombes
les portraits des hommes
pourtant les femmes ont lutté sous le
régime du chah et ont elles aussi eu
leur martin la lutte féminine a commencé
à l'iran avec la lutte si vous voulez
collecter des opposants contre la
répression et les femmes
ils sont allés en prison où ont été
torturées ont été martyrisés
exactement comme les hommes et de temps
en temps pire que je peux vous donner un
exemple d'une jeune fille d'azerbaïdjan
vécu et élevé dans une famille vraiment
traditionnelle et on l'a arrêté
on la torturait et n'a même pas voulu
prononcer son nom et on a mis du serpent
sur son corps on la vit au lait avec le
serpent est elle qui sortait d'une
famille si traditionnels et elle sans
culture il dit voilà moi je lutte et je
résiste pour une société où il eut la
question féminine ne se posera jamais il
n'y aura que l'égalité pour tous les
individus et moi j'en ferai partie comme
un délit et non comme une fin
je crois qu'il y beaucoup de femmes
tuées pendant la révolution
il ya eu beaucoup de femmes tuées
pendant la révolution et même avant la
révolution il ya eu des femmes qui ont
effectué sous la torture
il ya eu des femmes qui ont été qui ont
subi la peine capitale
et il ya eu des femmes
qui ont été tuées bouche avec en titre
voulait en combattant au champ de combat
est sûre il y a eu des fins qui ont dit
qu'is qui se sont si vous voulez du bien
sûr qu'ils se sont suicidés parce que
c'est ce et se font tuer pour sauver les
autres et pendant la révolution
le vendredi noir il ya eu beaucoup de
femmes puis parce que les femmes étaient
au premier rang
alors quand ils ont commencé à me trahir
les femmes étaient les premières qui ont
été abattus et ce jour là il ya eu 450
trains qui ont été abattus dans ce sens
la libération des femmes
la révolution n'a aucun sens ce slogan
elles sont plusieurs milliers à scander
dans les rues début mars
ce n'est pas comme on l'a dit souvent
pour protester uniquement contre le port
du voile
elles sont descendus spontanément dans
la rue parce que les premières
déclarations du nouveau gouvernement
on peut leur faire croire que là comme
ailleurs elles seraient les oubliés de
la révolution alors elles ont réagi on
les accusera très vite d'être des contre
révolutionnaires
pourtant femmes en tchador pour réclamer
le départ du shah femme dévoilée ensuite
pourquoi vouloir les opposer avant tout
ce sont des femmes dans l'action sortis
de leur foyer pour crier leur désir de
plus de démocratie
ensuite défendre leur droit d'être
elle-même
nous nous sommes rendus dans la rue il
ya eu deux femmes réactionnaires qui
appuyait le l'ex régime se sont rejoint
nos rangs et puis on comment dirais-je
et elles ont pris le problème de tchador
et puis on dit qu'on veut pas retourner
à l'esclavagé tout ça est tandis que
notre but n'était pas de tout cela et ce
jour là il ya eu des sommes ou donc
j'appelle les hommes de sa vague parce
que même s'ils sont peu nombreux mais
ils défendent cette mentalité quoi nous
ont attaqués et le soir même ayatollah
khomeini a dit qu' il ya des prix lucio
nerfs qui ont dérangé les femmes dans la
rue et puis il faut qu'elle soit qu'ils
soient poursuivis
par la suite il ya eu des femmes qui
défendent le régime du shah en profiter
de cette histoire de tchador et puis se
sont rendus dans les rues à plusieurs
reprises et puis c'est ça que nous
voulons pas qu'ils se produisent faisait
pas vraiment ça que les femmes demande
madame x aristocrate iranienne est
quelqu'un qu'on ne s'attend pas
d'ordinaire à trouver dans une
manifestation
pourquoi vous avez manifesté haut parce
que moi sur khomeiny d'abord il avait
dit que les femmes sont tout à fait égal
aux hommes mais aussitôt qu'ils étaient
ici il est arrivé ici il a commencé de
parler combler comme quelqu'un de moyen
âge on peut dire maintenant j'ose dire
que l'iran d'aujourd'hui sous khomeiny
et politiquement et socialement
exactement comme l'europe du moyen âge
bon vous savez que la dictature de
religion il ya quelque chose d'horrible
et pour la mentalité libre surtout et
maintenant nous nous sentons dans les
prisons justement c'est difficile de
respirer mais maintenant il manque
l'oxygène pour respirer librement
vous sentez persécutés oui de quelle
manière a lancé que vous risquez de
perdre votre travail vous pensez que
vous risquez d'être expulsé
justement je trouve quand nous sommes au
bord d'être de père tout ce que nous
avions eu juste maintenant maintenant on
n'ose pas dire ce qu'on veut dire
et puis les gens qui pensent qu'au moins
en son danger d'être tué
emprisonnés et maltraités sous le régime
du champ il y avait plus de liberté pour
toutes les femmes en iran que maintenant
oh je crois que oui je ne peux pas
parler de tous les fins toutes les
femmes
je peux parler des femmes qui voudraient
ceux étudiés qui voudraient travailler
et oui nous étions kong ou en euros vous
souhaiter le retour du champ we7
nombreux à le souhaiter d'après vous je
trouve que oui en tout les femmes qui
avaient manifesté même les femmes qui
avaient déjà manifesté pour monsieur
khomeiny maintenant sont contre lui et
trouve que le chat était libéral il
était démocratique au moins vers nous
les femmes de l'iran malgré la savak bon
le sava qui était un
et malheureusement été son compte les
communistes mais seulement contre les
communistes les autres gens s'ils
n'étaient pas comme nice était libre
mais maintenant il y a beaucoup de sa
vague mais beaucoup plus brutale qui est
d'abord parce que ça va vous pouvez vous
emprisonner je ne sais pas à torturer à
cause de quelque chose mais maintenant
sans preuve seulement parce que nous
vous vous marchez com - dans les rues en
est rennes en ce sens libre de vous
battre de vous frapper par couteau ou
bien vous vous faire ce qu'il veut et
tout le monde est armé maintenant alors
vous voyez le danger
par crainte que leur manifestation ne
donne lieu à des provocations les
organisations de gauche avaient
déconseillé aux femmes de poursuivre
leur action dans la rue et téhéran quand
nous y étions avait retrouvé son calme
quel a été votre position demande la
révolution j'étais tout à fait d'accord
avec la révolution et objets jetés dans
les manifestations aussi j'étais tout à
fait pour vous avez participé aux
manifestations de femmes qui ont eu lieu
ensuite
non parce que je n'étais pas d'accord
c'était trop vite
je crois que on n'a pas fini notre
révolution corps et on pouvait commencer
ça un peu plus tard cependant quand les
femmes ont cru qu'ils allaient être
obligés de porter le tchador je ne
trouvais pas ça normal qu'ils aient eu
envie de réagir
non parce que je n'étais pas d'accord
avec le tchador
je crois que il faut être égal avec les
ans et c'est tout mais il faut peut-être
se battre pour ça oui bien sûr mais
c'était un peu trop vite
qu'est-ce qui est le plus important pour
vous dans la situation actuelle le plus
important c'est que j'ai un pays libre
et je peux penser libre je peux te dire
ce que je veux dire mes idées je peux
travailler je peux faire tout ce que je
veux on ne me défends pas ici par
exemple on vous oblige à porter le voile
qu'est-ce qui vous allez faire je ne
reste pas au loup la question du voile
mais pas pour moi tellement important
c'est en question secondaire
si vraiment on ça on sait que notre
indépendance est en danger que nous que
la lutte contre l'impérialisme que nous
avons
jusqu'à 6 est en danger parce que nous
n'avons pas de voile moi je suis prêt à
porter le voile pendant des années 2000
voile nous ne voulons pas que quand on
nous parle du voile ça veut dire que
nous sommes obligés de créer un
mouvement de libération féminine
nous ne voulons pas de ça nous ne
voulons pas être séparées des hommes en
tant que temps nous voulons être des
individus et d'être reconnue d'un conte
fin mai n'ont pas avoir lu terminé je
suis contre cela vraiment quand il ya
une vraie révolution et c'est pour ça
que je crois que la révolution en iran
est une révolution incomplète parce que
liszt le système traditionnel le système
culturel le système politique existe
rien n'a encore changé
donc ça veut dire que cette société ne
va pas changer la situation de la femme
n'a pas changé lution que la traduction
existe parce que justement on n'a pas pu
bouleverser les bases de cette société
et peut-être que nous avons besoin d'une
deuxième reprise
à l'heure où s'écrivent ces lignes
chasser les ennemis hors d'iran et punir
les traîtres sont les dernières
consignes connu de l'ayatollah khomeini
les grandes compagnies étrangères
représentante d'un matérialisme qualifié
aujourd'hui de démoniaque ferment leurs
portes et annulent leur contrat
accélérant ainsi la fuite des capitaux
et la crise économique
malgré des rappels à l'ordre et
l'annoncent de la création d'une
compagnie de gardiens de la révolution
plus disciplinés les miliciens des
comités rosmini continue d'exercer
aujourd'hui leur pouvoir sans limite
dans la rue leurs excès de zèle comme
dans la sphère talent errani pourrait
bien provoquer plus vite que ne le
pensaient romane à terre une crise
ouverte et violentes au sein du pays
dirigeants iraniens ont par ailleurs à
faire face à des problèmes économiques
graves les chômeurs de plus en plus
nombreux les économiquement faibles
attendez que cette révolution leur
apporte aussi un mieux-être matériel et
commence à le faire savoir
pour l'instant rien n'a changé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en ce qui concerne les femmes la
situation n'est pas brillante
85% des femmes sont analphabètes et dans
leur immense majorité ne sont pas
salariés
ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'elle ne
travaille pas c'est le cas de la fille
d'un ouvrier agricole que nous avons
rencontrés à l'extérieur de téhéran dans
sa famille par tradition la femme n'a
jamais travaillé
pourtant ils sont cinq à vivre avec le
salaire du père l'équivalent de 450
francs par mois ils vivent dans
d'anciennes écuries sans confort que le
propriétaire du champ qu'ils exploitent
a bien voulu leur cds qu'elle croit que
quelque chose devrait être fait pour
changer le rôle des femmes pour qu'alizé
plus de liberté un magnifique une
coquille et olof varichon bat à nouveau
césar un battage la zone
elle dit que probablement pour pour les
autres femmes avant les conditions
étaient beaucoup plus libre que
maintenant après la révolution
mais pour l eau des femmes dans ces
conditions là rien n'a changé avant on
était potes libre et maintenant non plus
elles ne sont pas libres mais elle
espère que dans l'avenir la révolution
pour un simple améliorer leurs
conditions de vie sur place de l'homme
et la place de la femme dans leur
famille dans leur famille c'est plutôt
sa mère qui dirige la famille le père
travaille mais tout ce qu'ils gagnent
tout ce qu'il fait c'est dans l'amant de
sa femme c'est la femme qui qui organise
tout pour la famille
c'est plutôt le pouvoir de l'âme de la
femme dans cette famille que le pouvoir
de long pourquoi sont elles couvertes
est ce par tradition islamique et quel
est le rôle du mois wilson mathema
famille car à son sound sa monnaie puis
chemin d'un mode a imposé le ghana
meilleur 2e dan madame elle dit que
c'est aussi bien une tradition dans leur
famille que une tradition islamique dire
sa grand-mère sa mère elles ont toujours
porté une voile et elle porte aussi et
de l'autre côté serre c'est la religion
islamique qui demande que la femme soit
couverte et que qu'elle porte la voile
alors comme les musulmans elle porte
cette toile et c'est la religion qui
veut que le corps de la femme soit caché
ce qu'assure regarder la regardant mais
pour lui les femmes sont-elles égale à
l'homme ya benzema n'a pas marqué
morceaux viennent à vorey moussavi de
rand paul oui ils sont égales
est ce que la femme doit lui obéir
benzema brian âmes mortes chez marc
baucher palais elle doit obéir
sa femme ne lui obéit pas qu'est ce
qu'il fait aguer trois numéros de tous
moitié chemin à gauche et jacques cela
malines et j'aurai deux lyonnais
d'origine et leur vie de famille sera en
désordre et se disputeront les yeux il
aura des pays aura des problèmes
je trouve ici on a une culture féodal
dont qui a été depuis des années des
années
c'est pas parce que les hommes sont nos
ennemis mais c'est parce que on est
éduqué comme ça par exemple c'est
surtout c'est toujours un homme qui
décide pour la femme où on doit vivre si
on doit avoir des enfants ou si on doit
divorcer ou pas ou sur le plan du
mariage ne regardez pas dans les villes
par exemple il ya des femmes qui
choisissent leur mari mais dans beaucoup
d'autres coins du pays
les femmes sont mariées comme un objet
vous savez vous allez choisir un objet
vous l'acheter ou pas et c'est comme ça
que quand on considère la fin les hommes
sont supérieurs aux femmes à cause des
qualités par lesquelles dieu a élevé
cela au dessus de celle ci et parce que
les hommes emplois leurs biens pour
doter les femmes cette sourate iv du
coran est on ne peut plus clair
cependant cette situation ne fait que
réfléter ce qui était encore l'opinion
d'une grande partie du monde occidental
avant qu'on ne vienne y introduire la
notion de libération des femmes alors
qualifié immédiatement le schisme de
rétrograde ne voir dans son leader
religieux qu'un tyran du moyen-âge à
rome la ville sainte
lieu de pèlerinage important depuis que
khomeiny 10 habitent des iraniennes nous
ont dit que le coran contenait aussi
d'autres choses
l'idée d'une société sans classes une
aspiration à la pureté une conception
élevée de l'homme et de son rôle
[Musique]
l'arrivée au pouvoir des religieux les
mollahs qui exercent sur la population
un pouvoir moral et judiciaires risque
d'entraîner un durcissement une
application plus stricte des lois
coraniques
elles ont toujours existé ces lois même
du temps du shah qui avait mis en place
quelques lois protégeant les femmes et
leur donnant le droit de vote mais ne
change en rien dans les mentalités
plutôt que de parler des lois d'ailleurs
il faut parler d'une atmosphère et d'une
tradition
selon la tradition coranique plus ou
moins appliquée selon le degré de
culture des familles la femme ne choisit
pas son mari sans l'accord de ses
parents elle n'a pas le droit de voyager
ni de travailler sans l'accord de
celui-ci elle n'a droit qu'à une part
d'héritage quand l'homme en a deux elle
peut être répudiée sur simple demande du
mari et cetera et cetera
alors les droits fondamentaux des femmes
en iran sont ils menacés
on ne sait pas tant que ne sera pas mis
en place la constitution de la
république islamique
dès aujourd'hui cependant certains
signes laissent à penser que plus qu'une
affaire de droit c'est toute une
conception de la femme qu'il faut
changer
il était intéressant aussi de connaître
le point de vue de l'ayatollah shay as
tu m'as d'harry numéro deux du clergé
chiite qui nous avait-on dit avait
déclaré que les femmes ne pourraient pas
être juge binnie l'alambic n'avons
jamais dit que les femmes ne doivent pas
obligatoirement être jugé un vaisseau
dont les travaux durent pas
en plus les femmes d'accepter ces
emplois qui sont très dures hamrlik
rachis afta travolta john reid ancien
20e mondial en russie en amérique aux
états unis ou anglais en chine les
travaux difficiles ne sont pas occupés
par les femmes un exemple parmi les 37
président de la république américain il
n'y avait aucun contre une femme et
c'est seulement les devoirs très dur et
difficile qui empêchent les femmes je
les accepte et au rythme des vagues en
cours mais comment la justice cerveau
comme la justice pour être jugé
pour la direction de l'armée le chef de
l'armée ou les sénateurs dans les dents
le sénat qui ne sont pas les farines
nord notamment le même la cata bord des
bardages kibera de pousser millevaches
in a day un jour je n'ai pas seulement
celui qui va unir au bureau et qui reste
dans son dos en local mais qui qui
doivent s'affronter avec beaucoup de
problèmes qui voit les gens qui sont
atteints par les balles ou bien qu'ils
ont beaucoup de difficultés c'est la
racine hadad
le bien-être de la femme qui la lampe
est acceptée c'est donc le pensez vous
que des femmes puissent participer à un
gouvernement dans une république
islamique dans le quartier moulin bonnet
dans les travaux qui sont même bien pour
les familles les imposteurs
l'ue met par exemple pour être le
commandant cher une femme ne peut pas
être pas faire ça la femme n'a pas la
force pure sucre tous les travaux ou
bien parce qu'elle est très délicate et
sensible elle peut pas faire un tous les
travaux vous savez les femmes iraniennes
ont participé toujours dans la
révolution depuis 70 ans
ils ont joué elles ont joué un grand
rôle dans la révolution
constitutionnelle durant il ya 72 ans au
début de ce siècle dont tout l'est dans
tous les moments historiques de du
peuple iranien les femmes ont joué un
rôle clé c'était pas la première fois
mais comme il y avait la pression il y
avait là la terreur de la sava et du
régime de l'ancien régime les femmes
comme tout l'ensemble des sociétés
n'avaient aucun droit de s'organiser et
c'est pour ça il y avait des
organisations plein de styles ce dont on
peut pas dire qu'il y avait pas
d'organisation la révolution de dia
quelques mois ça a fait qu'ils aient
farid et appartient à l'une des trois
organisations féministes nouvellement
créée qui sont encore très très
minoritaire cependant l'union
révolutionnaire des femmes combattantes
à laquelle elle appartient regroupe déjà
selon elle quelques 500 femmes à téhéran
et à travers le pays
vous êtes organisé pourquoi nous sommes
organisés pour lutter contre le régime
du shah et c'est pas trop impérialiste
qui soient américaines russes ou les
autres c'était pour participer dans la
révolution du peur et puis pour faire
parvenir une certaine humiliation
famille
est-ce que s'est fixé le défunt par quel
moyen elle
vous y prendre pour faire accepter vos
revendications c'est-à-dire nous
organisons nous devrions nous organisons
des meetings des des manifestations de
nous distribuons des tracts envoyant des
lettres ouvertes au gouvernement par
tous les moyens qu on essaie de faire
accepter du casting vous avez confiance
dans l'avenir
[Musique]
oui j'ai confiance en eux mêmes et je ne
profère de traduire ça pour nos
brillants des études il ya tant de
livres de cuisine bien ce que mange quoi
nous nous appuyons sur la force des
femmes qui travaillent des femmes qui
sont opprimés qui n'ont aucun droit dans
la société et les femmes pour la
la moitié de la société elles ont
beaucoup de force
elle joue du grande un grand rôle dans
la cellule dans la révolution parce
qu'elles ont un rôle clé dans le dos la
famille les élèves les femmes et les
enfants ils peuvent donner beaucoup de
choses à dire en quoi elles la
suppression de toute oppression des
femmes ce sera réalisée après la
révolution qui est pas de pression de la
société
les groupes de femmes qui commencent à
se constituer en iran ne sépare pas leur
lutte d'un combat politique plus
générale
ainsi elles se sont associées à des
organisations laïques qui avait été à la
pointe du mouvement révolutionnaire
comme le front démocratique et les
fedayin marxiste pour appeler au boycott
du référendum à l'abstention
trop chaud
cependant on a l'impression qu'elles ont
les mains liées pour l'instant est que
quelle que soit l'issue du combat qui se
prépare entre les opposants progressiste
et le pouvoir religieux
on peut craindre qu'une fois de plus les
femmes n'en fassent les frais vous savez
je crois que le problème de la femme est
tout de même très important je ne crois
pas du tout qu'il va se résoudre
automatiquement à travers des luttes
politiques
[Musique]
je crois que les ambiguïtés de la part
du pouvoir en ce moment quand
quant à la question de la femme font
partie des ambiguïtés de 7
[Applaudissements]
idéologie révolutionnaire et religieuses
en même temps qu'ils voudraient se
formuler mais qui n'a pas encore ses
formules à mon avis c'est parce que les
réalités de lure en sont tout de même
très différente de ce que certains
pensent que l'iran est un pays de
diversité de diversité de cultures de
langues de couture voyez l'image de la
femme iranienne
la femme kurde la femme deluce la femme
paysanne la femme sur la caspienne la
femme sur le golfe persique
c'est tout de même très différent de
l'image que une idéologie monolithique
et conformiste voudrait proposer comme
l'image de l'iran et de la femme
d'abord il faut pas voir la femme
iranienne comme celle qui a jusqu'à il
ya 50 ans porter le voile
ensuite qu'on lui a retiré le voile
maintenant qu'on lui impose le voile
c'est pas ça la femme paysanne crânienne
n'a jamais porté le voile la question de
non mixité ne s'est jamais posée dans la
campagne iranienne la femme qui
travaille dans l' usine a toujours
travaillé à côté de l'homme la femme
iranienne dans la famille je suis sûr
qu'on vous l'a déjà dit elle a un rôle
très important
elle est toujours
dans l'espace de la maison avec les
sommes qu'il soit le mari ou le 6 ou le
cousin où les gens qui viennent à la
maison elle a l'habitude d'être de vivre
avec le sexe masculin donc
donc je crois qu'elle va mener sa vie
je crois que il est faux de penser
qu'une révolution peut faire table rase
dans aucun pays c'est vrai ce n'est pas
vrai à téhéran plus l'eau monte vers le
nord plus le niveau de vie s'élève tout
à fait au sud donc c'est le quartier de
la misère des bidonvilles
c'est un moyen âge économique celui là
que l'on découvre ici les femmes ont
toujours porter le tchador fait
peut-être là office de cache-misère
vivent ici les exclus manoeuvre artisans
chômeurs il est trés pour la plupart qui
massivement on espérait le changement de
leur situation grâce à l'islam
les quartiers sud servent un peu de
baromètre du climat social à téhéran
quand nous y sommes allés les gens
fêtaient la victoire du référendum nous
y avons rencontré ma vie' couturière
pour les femmes de son quartier son mari
était ouvrier mais emprisonné et torturé
pendant six mois par la savak il avait
perdu son emploi elle vit avec ses deux
soeurs leurs maris leurs enfants treize
personnes dans quatre pièces ces
journées commencent à 5h le matin et se
termine vers minuit elle a trois enfants
hélas 33 ans pays tu vas tu as dans sa
famille l'homme et la femme se sont
pratiquement égal il trappe
enfin ils travaillent tous les deux et
l'homme à sa place dans la famille qui
est le responsable de la famille et la
femme à sa place qui aussi laid ils ont
leur être responsable de la vie
familiale dedans et elles sont
pratiquement nigon et ils ont une valeur
égale l'un pour l'autre
est-ce que son mari l'aide dans les
tâches de la maison bien est ce qu elle
considère que ce n'est pas le rôle d'un
jeune talent du snav
c'est elle même qui n'aiment pas que son
mari fasse quelque chose à la maison
elle elle n'a pas du tout voir un nombre
travailler à la maison ou faire des
travaux de ménage ou s'occuper des
enfants
alors
elle trouve que ça baisse la valeur de
l'homme si la révolution devait changer
quelque chose dans sa vie de femme
qu'est ce qu'elle aimerait que ce soit
des kings et zones 1 à 5 et j'aurai la
chance elle trouve qu'il ne faut pas
être très très strict alors mettre des
lois très strictes pour la 20e pole
parce que ça ne donne rien
elle demande que la révolution fasse
quelque chose contre la drogue parce que
ici surtout dans leur quartier
il ya une trafic de drogue il ya plein
de drogués aussi bien des femmes que les
hommes
et ça fait c'est très mauvais pour le
tous les drogués et c'est un mauvais
exemple pour pour les gens qui vivent
ici généralement assez idiot tu n'as
voyage il a dit qu'il ne trouve pas
qu'il faudrait embêter les femmes avec
le tchador
bien sûr elle est le porte parce qu'il
est habitué mais ne trouve pas que c'est
obligatoire pour les femmes
elle trouve de la femme comme ses trois
filles elle veut que par exemple ses
trois filles fassent des études de mana
et ravailler sp puisse être libre dans
la société à avoir une liberté
économique est une liberté sociale alors
le tchador c'est une chose qui est un
peu embêtant pour la femme alors une
femme qui veulent apporter elle porte
une autre femme qui ne veut pas ne la
porte pas et le tchador n'est pas une
garantie pour l'honneur de la femme
est ce qu'une femme sans trader peut
être très honorable et une femme avec le
tchador peut être même une prostituée
alors il n'ya pas c'est pas une garantie
quelle est la place attribué
généralement à la femme dans la société
par l'islam
l'épisode a terminé à bodélio mais hamas
n'a au dessus aussi
bertossa dit dans toutes leurs
dimensions de la société et villa de
rôle politique et économique
elle partage un étage bidon mais avec l
islam avec tous les spéciales où les
spécificités que nous avons avec lequel
on connaît l'islam de maintenant il doit
garder ses spécificités féminines et ils
gardaient les tâches rémy nicklaus à la
famille qu est ce que ça veut dire que
les femmes pour le slam en plus leur
place à la maison avec les enfants au
foyer des hommes à l'extérieur pour
travailler et doivent avoir moins de
liberté que les hommes dans la société à
sainte marcelline nick et moi allons
nous attarder dink est désormais partagé
envoyé chars au real ou d'amener un
double des clés ce n'est pas la fin on
doit être très limité à la maison à
travailler seulement avec les enfants
les ménages et tout ça nous croyons que
la femme doit travailler dehors
avec l'ombre en gardant tous ses
spécificités féminines au lounge bar il
est très actif et travailler dehors
c'est une nécessité mais c est encore
ont nécessité religieux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
y at il des restrictions imposées aux
femmes dans la société islamique par
exemple maquillage l'habillement ou
d'autres choses
hollande tatum gi quasi choix qui mena
la guitare ghost mania sensible youlou
bien les bosses win or has nasa les
escaliers aller chez ricoh a menacé rue
de llauro dote à l'abonné et la surcote
bon hélico ceux qui condamnent island
c'est les qualités aux mains c'est ça
qui compte
c'est après ça qu'on joue une personne
il n'ya pas d'élite des limitations
spéciale ce qui compte c'est d'être est
couverte et par exemple rompre société
capitaliste on en beaucoup d'attention
en fait beaucoup d'attention à
l'extérieur et ça c'est objectif y est
la femme mais pour nous ce qui compte
c'est que la femme avoir une couverte
échos c'est intérieur et qualité humains
soient jugés pourquoi ne pourrait-on pas
les hommes à la main sur malte rome
bhushan bahree analyste à l'extérieur de
fans de sa qui excitent les gens et
c'est pour ça qu'en en concours les
spécificités sexuelle de l'afar tel
droit auront les femmes de choisir
elles-mêmes leurs époux et le mode de
vie avec lui un an après ma deuxième de
motorola samatanais ce tous les droits
coloma
la femme a aussi il n'y a pas de
questions là tu n'es pas de problème à
la télévision règne le docteur sa
dérobade est il oblige les speakerines
apparaître voilée et filtrent les
informations qui pourraient être
critiques à l'égard du nouveau régime
il fallait connaître mieux l'opinion de
celui que les féministes désigne un peu
comme leur ennemi principal une forme
stone tout la mer oh si vous voulez une
femme ça à la fois travailleurs
éducatrice et un président ou une
présidente une députée le droit défendre
exactement égouts les droits de l'homme
aucune différence entre les femmes et
les hommes je crois d'abord que la femme
iranienne ont été opprimés supprimés
pendant des années des années
au contraire de conception islamique et
c'est pour ça la femme iranienne et
participer dans cette résolution une
farouche long pour l'islande
tant qu'elle a appris à l'islam pour la
femme c'est une jolie fille libre
actrice et sol alors liberté ce sera
garantie par l'islande pour l'avenir moi
je n'ai pas vraie peur de l'islam ou de
l'idéologie islamique ou d'un mais j'ai
peur du fascisme qui est en train de
naître à l'iran pour la première fois
j'ai peur de feu ennemi imaginaire qui
sont en train de créer un jour c'est par
exemple un tel fait qd un jour c'est par
exemple disons ça feu les juifs
un jour c'est excellent
les homosexuels un jour ce sont par
exemple les prostituées du sud de la
ville et le et demain ça sera les
moudjahidine les fadas illégaux la
gauche ait su aussi les libres penseurs
et ceux qui n'accepteront pas enfin leur
formule pour ce qui est bon et pour ce
qui est mauvais c'est de ça que je vois
que vraiment et il parle de temps en
temps quand il parle à la télévision ces
gens là vraiment ça nous rappelle d'une
manière terrible les discours vous savez
populiste et démagogique de hitler et de
mussolini et surtout quand il parle de
là bas et quand il s'adresse aux fins de
quelle manière cette reste il vous savez
que moi j'ai justement ramet reconsulter
engagé mais si vous voulez des regarder
encore les discours comme les moussons
l'uni et hitler s'adresser à dresser
adressé aux femmes en leur disant que
voilà que vous de votre premier rôle est
d'être la mère allemande que la grande
halle allemand l'allemagne et représente
en bout c'est vous qui avait engendré
nos soldats c'est vous qui avait
engendré l'héroïsme c'est vous que vous
savez c'est ce qu'on entend se sortent
discours à sommes adressés aux femmes a
dressé par exemple aux soldats adressé
au peuple me sens définir la position de
par exemple on parle du peuple tout
entier comme comme vous savez une masse
sans couleur une masse qui n'a pas de
forme dans l'es2 une masse dans laquelle
l'individu
pierce a sa personnalité c'est du
fascisme c'est ça coûte c'est de ça que
je perds parce que quand on veut les r
quelqu'un ou quand on protège quelqu'un
ça veut dire que vous étaient protégés
ça veut dire que vous êtes des opprimés
on ne protège et jamais quelqu'un que
quand on vous le considérez et qu'allah
vous mais vous protéger les faibles
alors déjà nous sommes considérés comme
comme les faibles de ces sociétés et
c'est de ça que j'ai peur quand il ose
quand ils sont trop bons envers non
c'est ça qui fait peur quand ils nous
ignorent c'est déjà mieux
en tant que femme qu'est ce qui vous
fait peur dans l'islam savez j'ai été
élevé dans cette culture il est
difficile de dire que ce qui me fait
peur pratiquement rien dans l'islam tels
que je l' ai vécu rien mais dans les
flammes conques on vous prépare enfin
dans l'islam à la mode iranienne tels
que le rêve monsieur khomeiny moi je
vois cette révolution d'une façon
vraiment différente
je me vois pour la première fois dans ma
vie dans un pays qui est disons ouvert à
toute activité pour le moment dans un
pays qui n'a pas sur ses épaules cette
peur
de la police politique alors pour le
moment je respire je respire je ne suis
pas tellement traumatisée vous voyez et
je crois que la vraie question du
pouvoir et qui va l'emporter qui va la
gagner
se pose où les les différents aspects de
la vie vont au fur et à mesure se poser
et se se réaliser se résoudre dans cette
nouvelle situation
c'est à dire je suis très
inquiètes et impatiente pour voir
comment nos enfants vont s'élever dans
la révolution dans le pays que nous
aurons aujourd'hui demain et après
demain je voudrais voir quelles sont
quels seront mes rapports avec les gens
que je vais rencontrer dans l'espace
public
c'est tout ça qui me passionne j'ai pas
peur
cependant vous ne pensez pas que dans
votre vie des femmes
gd chose qui risque de changer avec les
lois islamiques par exemple nous allons
lutter pour vous voyez c'est ça qui est
bien c'est que avant il n'y avait pas y
avait pas une chance pour lutter pour
revendiquer maintenant sept cette chance
se voit est ce que vous ne pensez pas
que les problèmes que ceux qu'on se pose
là sont les problèmes des intellectuels
de téhéran et ne sont pas les problèmes
de l'ensemble des phares à dire ou pas
du tout les problèmes des femmes sont
les problèmes des femmes qui travaillent
dans le parce que les intellectuels
n'ont pas de problème parce qu'elle
vient toujours des de bourgeoisie hautes
elles ne sont pas des problèmes vraie
façon privilégiée
les problèmes sont des femmes parce que
moi je travaille je pourrais être un fin
conduit socialement égale à l'homme et
tout ça tu sais parce que je suis j'ai
eu la possibilité étudiée d'aller au
dehors de l'argent tout ça est alors je
peux travailler et si je veux le faire
pas les choses de maison je peux avoir
une femme qui me dit m non les femmes du
peuple sont les faits les femmes du pop
qui a tout les problèmes pour moi à la
contraception là
à l'avortement tout ça ne sont pas des
problèmes les fans de pop ne connaissait
encore et qu'est ce que ça veut dire la
contraception est là elle fait effet
beaucoup d enfants et nous sommes elle
n'a pas encore la conscience de leurs
problèmes de faim et la conscience de
lutte et a maintenant les et la
conscience de vous le volet vouloir
quelque chose vous en avez rencontré des
femmes du peuple qui lutte
oui mais quel laquelle tu vois
aujourd'hui j'ai parlé avec une femme
elle n'est pas un conte a dit nulle part
elle fait de travail est très difficile
et va de maison à l'autre pour des piles
et les femmes elle a participé aux
luttes pour la révolution et elle a
participé et elle a dit qu'elle va voter
pour la république islamique et je le
provoquais impôts pour savoir pourquoi
elle jeudi twonav atouts n'a pas peur de
moules à des choses comme ça et là dit
no parce que j'ai jeté le chat dehors et
je peux le jeter au mini dehors silvan
être à notre lecteur mais elle croit
qu'elle connaît ni ne travaille comme ça
ne sera pas un autre dictateur et vous
même c'est ce que vous en pensez
la même chose donc l'avenir vous semble
comment très joli
je sais c'est vraiment une printemps du
liberté pour moi mais elles sont pas
seulement sur les logan mais parce que
je me sens tout diverses
je n'ai pas plus porte voûtée et
[Musique]
c'était très important
moi je crois que en ce moment en iran
l'enjeu tout l'enjeu et la démocratie il
faut lutter pour la démocratie et de
sueur et à mesure qu'on développe le
thème de la démocratie que le peuple
iranien s'habitue à faire l'exercice de
la démocratie
tous les autres aspects enfin je c'est
faux de dire tous les autres aspects
mais tous les aspects d'une vie
démocratique
ce rebond le temps et l'espace de se
développer
comment peut-on être moderne dans le
présent gardé son identité et prévoir la
future pour
[Musique]
pour pouvoir aussi être faire partie du
monde entier c'est ça qui est très
important je crois que tout ce discours
mystifiant orient occident et pour
voiliers pour eux pour cacher le fait
que le destin de l'homme destin de la
femme en ce moment dans le monde entier
est le même nous avons nos spécificités
culturelles nous avons une différence
nous tenons à garder notre identité mais
il faut pas tout de même essayer de
devoir l'iranienne dans un cadre
complètement différent je crois que
finalement nous ne sont pas tellement
différents de vous que nos luttes ont si
vous voulez un seul but un seul but
lequel c'est de pouvoir être nous-mêmes
et de vivre dans des sociétés libres
[Musique]